hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I am finally back in my own I
haven't even been able to start the new
year because I've been touring since the
2nd of January and I just got back two
days ago because I drove back from
Cincinnati Ohio to Los Angeles LA so she
got a great time in Cincinnati it was
totally worth the trip I really wish
that she could have met buddy and it's
really sad that she didn't but chica
brought a lot of joy to my family
especially my stepmom who was really
missing buddy and now my stepmom is
probably gonna be getting another dog
but gonna wait until the summer so it's
a little warmer out there it's real cold
out in Cincinnati but I'm back it took
three days of driving to get back and I
was driving alone and I was just lost in
my own thoughts and it's totally fine
cuz I'm an introvert and I need all the
time I could get but I was lost my
thoughts all by myself alone but I'm
back and I'm back for another three
weeks until I go back on tour in Europe
yay more traveling it's gonna be so
worth it though the tour was
unbelievably fun we actually shot a big
special for the whole show we had a
professional videographer following us
through the whole tour we had someone
interviewing us at every stop we
professionally shot the Las Vegas show
with like a six camera set up in a
director and a whole team behind it and
so we've got a lot of really cool
footage to make a cool documentary now I
don't know when that's gonna be done but
when it's done I'll try to figure out a
way to release it that is most
advantageous for everything we're not
gonna post it on YouTube probably but we
will try to make it so that it's readily
available to as many people as possible
without being an inconvenience also now
if you want to go see us on the tour we
are still going to the European
shows go-to toward markiplier come to
see them for yourself you want to know
where I'll tell you with words starting
on February 14th which is the
Valentine's Day Valentine's Day we're
going to Tilburg Netherlands Antwerp
Belgium Paris France Amsterdam
Netherlands London UK Cardiff Manchester
Glasgow Nottingham I didn't say any of
those right Cologne Germany Berlin
Germany Oslo Norway Copenhagen Denmark
Stockholm Sweden so if you haven't
gotten a ticket yet to see us in Europe
we are coming your way so thank you so
much for that also if you go to Marga
Blair calm without the tour go -
markiplier calm you can see I've got
brand new merch finally I've got this
one which I really really love it's
super comfy but it says although giggle
a [ __ ] ignore the fact that it's
backwards hope that I can't even bother
to explain why but it says I'm a giggly
[ __ ] on there there's a whole bunch of
other stuff available right now on the
website if you go to markiplier comm and
you haven't seen one of the cool things
that I've got up there go check it out
right now
there's also a van t-shirt there's logo
t-shirt there's a hat there's a blanket
there's tons of stuff so check it out
for yourselves in other haven't done
like a [ __ ] news update and so long
and been able to do in other news I am
going to be streaming on Twitch more
regularly now that does not mean that I
am NOT gonna be streaming on youtube
that just means I've actually got it set
up ready to go I did a test stream
yesterday and it was super fun just
because I actually have things under
control twitches a little better set up
the communities more established as far
as live-streaming goes and it was just
all-around fun to be able to play games
that I wouldn't ordinarily consider to
be let's play material but you know what
is let's play material anyway it doesn't
mean anything but what I do really enjoy
about live streaming is it gives us
interactivity between you and I and I
have it set up in a way that makes chat
very very conversable and fun to do so
I'm gonna be streaming over there if you
want to go over and follow me there
bribe you can go through markable our
twitch TV / markiplier and you can go
see that for yourself in other news I am
back in the new year this is a new year
2018 I haven't even been able to do a
freaking review of my best videos from
the past year god dammit I meant to do
that but I got so busy with the tour and
prepping for Christmas that I didn't get
a chance to so here I am already almost
a month into 2018 and I am not there I'm
sorry I'm a big piece of [ __ ] I hate
myself so what I need from you guys and
this is kind of important if you guys
can help me out and in the comments
below let me know what your favorite
videos of 2017 were we did a lot of
really cool stuff this year from a date
with markiplier tomorrow RTVE - who
killed marklar to all the other sketches
in between there we did a lot of cool
stuff we did live streams we did
sketches we did music stuff we did we
did a whole bunch of stuff so I want to
know what you guys really really enjoyed
of last year because going into this
next year I'm gonna be doing different
things because last year was very much
my what can i push how goodly can I push
the stuff that I make this next year
like I want it to be the year where I
explore different things maybe outside
of videos with different concepts that I
normally wouldn't approach when it comes
down to playing video games or writing a
book or doing music or stuff like that
like there's a whole bunch of other
things that I want to do but I do want
to reflect upon 2017 as a year as a
whole so let me know what your favorite
part of 2017 is down in the comments
below I would love to know and I want to
create another playlist because I kind
of do that every year of the best videos
of the past year I mean other news I
know that everybody in the comments is
going to shout at the top of their lungs
all the games that they want me to play
I have a big-ass list of over 42 games
42 games that I've downloaded and I have
ready to go for Let's Plays that I'm
going to be doing very very immediately
at the top of the list is your favorites
like subnautica I've got smaller crowd
I've got
perception I've got the okay that game
okay all right that game probably
already I recorded that one this morning
if it came out at 8:00 a.m. you know uh
weird game but I've got a whole bunch of
them if you have another suggestion that
you want me to play a game I swear I
know I've been hearing you guys I know
exactly what you Shh it's okay sure sure
it's alright my god
I got it trust me my gosh I got it hey
hey look I got it
look it's okay got it please no no you
still comedy no no no no anyway so this
year is going to be a lot of fun I only
have about three weeks until I have to
go out again for the tour in Europe but
in that time I'm going to be as
productive as I possibly can I've got a
lot of stuff that I'm working on my own
I've got a lot of stuff that I want to
work on I've gotten a lot of ambition
this year and you're gonna see a lot of
cool and different stuff than you're
usually seeing for me I've been getting
really good at guitar I've been getting
a lot better at singing you know I've
been doing a lot more like experimental
stuff and I've been doing some writing
on my own it's been a it's been a really
good year for me and and another thing
that I want to do is I want to keep
doing these um weekly update videos you
know markiplier Mondays or whatever I
used to call them III I miss doing them
because it just is another way that I
can connect with you guys and another
way that I can actually talk with you
guys on a regular basis and keep you in
the loop of what I'm doing because
there's a lot of guesswork that happens
a lot of time but especially when the
community gets as big as it is it's
almost at 20 million which is just
unbelievable think about and those
tasteful nudes I gotta I gotta get on
this I gotta get on those you know step
number one is getting in shape enough
because I've kind of let myself go over
the Christmas break it's very hard to
this workout when you're on tour but
don't you don't you worry let me worry
about me don't you worry about me
let me worry about naked so I've got a
lot of things on my mind and I've got a
lot of things that I want to do you know
to start up the new year I'm just really
in a good place
I I wasn't a good place I'm not saying
that at the end of the last year I
wasn't a bad place I was actually in a
really good place then too but I've got
a lot of hope through this year and I've
got a lot of I've got a lot of you know
resolutions but they all kind of
narrowed down to doing more and talking
less because I think talking about doing
stuff is what makes you go crazy because
if you can't fulfill what you talk about
that it just makes things in an endless
loop but for what I want to do I think
it's gonna be pretty cool so I'm gonna
try to do update videos update vlogs
every Monday I can't promise you know
I'll be super regular about that but
they also will not always be in this
room me talking to you guys right here I
want to go out and bow more I've got
other things that I want to do I got the
classes that I want to take things that
I want to learn in things that I should
be a pretty exciting year least on this
side so thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know what you think down
in the comments below of what your
favorite video the last year was in
anything other you're gonna say to me
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye boy goodbye
[Music]